on a vidé et les partenaires à des 100
gratuitement spécifique pour nos
adhérents et cette année on atteint 48
exposants dans tous les musées toujours
les matériaux nouveaux
on laisse que les gens connaissent c'est
intéressant ce qu'on veut c'est que les
adhérents viennent pour le savoir
qu'elle puisse y ait du nouveau et
commence à être demain il ya eu un gros
frein parce que la bike locaux vides
bien sûr des gens qui avaient fait
d'être avoir faire ne faut pas rester
sans vouloir les faire mais la
conjoncture les freiner dans leur
décision
suite à leur sortie confinement il ya
une pause demande une très grosse de
vente début sept ans et la fera un total
de 14 jours sans doute suite au
gouvernement qui prend des décisions
[Musique]
le confinement a fait que les gens qui
avaient un petit à petit un petit chez
soi
et puis un beau petit jardin c'était
beaucoup mieux pour que 10 auckland ils
se sentent un peu intéressé pour
améliorer leur bien-être
est-ce que leur vie est confiné et quand
on dit qu'on finit dans un bien d'un
chez soi qu'ils soient passés quand même
beaucoup mieux mais c'est reste
maintenant à peu la quiétude
le demain parce que je pense qu'il ya un
mode de vie qui va changer